to redo that my way from despising the
director or signing super long contracts
or accepting roles that just weren't
meant for them it sounds like actors
have a million different reasons for why
they regret the roles they take on let's
check out some of them now didn't you
guys do a movie together you did Green
Lantern it was definitely Greenland
right
number one are you surprised to hear
that not every single actor is happy
they joined the MCU at some points over
her time filming Elizabeth Olsen
seriously regretted being part of the
Marvel franchise at all due to it
costing her other roles because she was
locked in on a multi-year contract while
we all adored her performance and we are
sure she did enjoy her time filming as
well actors don't like to sit still for
very long I started this whole journey
with Marvel eight years ago and now I'm
tired number two actually there are a
few actors who just didn't walk away
from Marvel feeling totally fulfilled
Marissa Tomei regrets playing Aunt May
in the MCU for no other reason then
she's worried she'll end up Typecast
into the mom roles and won't be able to
escape them at the same time she did
Spider-Man she also played a mom in the
king of Staten Island and that's enough
for Hollywood to see you as one thing
and one thing only apparently at least
she gets to play the quirky motherly
roles and not the boring ones like Sally
Field who we're getting to shortly and
hey she really had to push for that
awesome Arc in Spider-Man no way home
number three it's hard to forget Sam
Puckett we imagine it's even harder for
Jeanette McCurdy she was forced into
acting by her mom at six years old and
by 10 or 11 she was the breadwinner for
her family on iCarly she decided to step
away from acting for good just a few
years ago due to a complete lack of what
Hollywood's supplying she said I feel so
unfulfilled by the roles that I played
and felt like it was the most cheesy
embarrassing I did the shows that I was
on from like 13 to 21 and by 15 I was
already embarrassed and if you want to
hear her full story make sure to grab a
copy of her tell-all book I'm glad my
mom died our hearts go out to you
Jeanette it's very important to walk
away in in no uncertain terms at that
time number four do you think she was
told before her audition the details of
the characters she was portraying the
character Emma Stone played in Aloha was
based on a real life person who is
quarter Hawaiian and quarter Chinese
they'd initially defended the choice by
saying that the character Crow based her
on didn't immediately look like her
background however that's not a good
enough excuse to stand on and Emma's
become the butt of jokes over it number
five do you dare Play The Man in the
skin-tight red costume Ben Affleck said
I hate Daredevil so much it frustrated
me yeah before Disney saved comic book
movie adaptations there was the 2003
Daredevil we were all happy to forget he
admitted the Netflix show does really
cool stuff I feel like that was there
for us to do with the character and we
never kinda got it right I wanted to do
one of those movies and sort of get it
right the one thing Affleck does reflect
on as a good experience from that movie
was working with the blind performer Tom
Sullivan stating a lot of the other
stuff was kind of silly number six there
are so many superhero movies actors is
long to forget Ryan Reynolds never even
finished watching Green Lantern and once
he took up the Marvel role and turned
the DC lights out for good he definitely
mocked the movie in character as
Deadpool pretending to blow his brains
out for accepting the role in the first
place God damn that's beautiful
number seven what is it with Aunt May
Sally Field felt that Aunt May was
completely one-dimensional in The
Amazing Spider-Man while it is true that
she exists in every Universe to support
Peter Parker in this one specifically
her support stopped at laundry she said
it's really hard to find a
three-dimensional character in it and
you work it as much as he can but you
can't put 10 pounds of [ __ ] in a five
pound bag number eight there's enough
roles out there for a cisgender dude I
still haven't necessarily reconciled
whether that was the yeah whether it was
the right thing to do Eddie Redmayne
received an Oscar nomination for his
role in the Danish girl that didn't stop
him from saying taking on the role was a
mistake though being a cisgendered man
playing a transgender woman is just no
just no don't do it number 9. John
boyega isn't happy with the Star Wars
sequels he admitted what I would say to
Disney is do not bring out a black
character Market them to be much more
important in the franchise than they are
and then have them pushed to the side
it's not good I'll say it straight up
Not only was John boyega upset about his
portrayal he also didn't like the way
Kelly Marie Tran was treated either
number 10. being a Hollywood heartthrob
can really pigeonhole you into only
getting one type of work everything
about me invites you in my voice my face
even my smell and let's be real most men
don't want to act in rom-coms they want
to be in superhero movies unless they're
the other superheroes on this list
Robert Pattinson shamelessly admitted
had he not been in Twilight he would
have mindlessly hated it the only props
this actor took from set were the
underwear because dang were they comfy
now that's one way to show your complete
disinterest in a franchise number 11.
it's no secret that Shailene was
disappointed by the show's trajectory
Shailene Woodley loved the first three
episodes of Secret Life of the American
Teenager when she'd read the script she
thought they were absolutely Progressive
and reflected the real life experiences
of people she'd known in high school so
she took on the role unfortunately the
evolution of the show did not stay in
line with the three episodes she'd read
as the show continued to swing more
conservative in nature over its Five
Seasons the characters began shaming
others for premarital intercourse and
she was just not a fan number 12. it was
a GI no for Channing Tatum he admitted
I'll be honest I [ __ ] hate that movie
he was pressured into doing GI Joe and
he found the script terrible but it
wasn't just the script he wasn't sure he
wanted to do a movie version of a show
he loved he really didn't know if he
even wanted to be GI Joe are you
surprised he didn't want to play a
character he adored number 13 most
actors do not go and accept their own
golden raspberry Awards most they
usually have some sort of um Pride or
shame one of those but Halle Berry has
neither in this case she felt the
product she'd made was garbage and so
wasn't afraid to show her face and
accept her award for Catwoman saying
thank you so much
number 14 this role was transformational
for the actor's spine what wasn't to
hate about Transformers for her Megan
Fox and director Michael Bay just did
not get along she didn't like the way
she was being treated so young and like
a piece of eye candy and speaking of
candy I cut my uh my hands because they
didn't replace the glass in the truck
with candy glass she slipped a disc too
that was pretty brutal my back is never
the same it will never be okay ever
again number 15 women want to play the
fun roles too Catherine Heigl thought
Knocked Up was a little sexist because
it Paints the women as shrews as
humorless and uptight and it Paints the
men as lovable goofy fun-loving guys
she'd much rather be in a movie that
defies any of those stereotypes thank
you
there's no winning in Hollywood actors
are just going to complain about
anything and everything their superhero
costumes are too tight their series is
too successful and too many girls are
fawning over them well we won't even get
into the movie cats do you find
typecasting has gone too far in
Hollywood let us know in the comments
and if you like hanging out with us
subscribe to the things no we're serious
when we say we probably could have found
15 actors who regretted being in the
movie Cats